[Música]
pero está hechizado en ti
Dios mío, tu MA
[Música]
hola
ese hechizo en Dios mío
[Música]
ja
ah
[Música  ]
Puedo
[Música]
[Música
] nunca dejarás a un bebé puedes decir
[Música] de
todos modos la mujer bori tomó una
[Música]
cuando los veo ganar demasiado dinero
pop justo en  hogar dile a tu bebé que nunca
gastes una mujer
de todas las cosas
quiero arreglarme el cabello en una foto
[Música] el
corpiño de sousou-sama se está quemando pero te
gusta vestirte
deja de hacerlo tienes suelto ve a casa en el
sur hizo un bien no entendí espero
que encuentres  allí mismo, la ficción
[Música]
difícil de detener en cualquier lugar para pagar
que estuvo atascado todo el tiempo, ¿
sigues sentado bien? Mi desesperación significa
otro sr.  ting y la forma en que te gusta
y te gusta bien como hoy, no vengas,
oh, deja de hacer el tonto
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hacer samosas yo y mi gato
caliente oh Dios mío fuiste rápido a lo que ellos
saben mucho más con todo el yo y mi
gato
[Música]
solo nos despedimos con palabras llegué a
casa él volverá a eso ¿puedo volver?
a eso que todos esperábamos
te amo demasiado no es ideal
no rodarás oh y me amo es como un
cinco agrupado en flexión pinto en un abanico
rodando de las paredes quién disparó siempre
[música]
vuelves a  el volver a ella y
yo vuelvo a
damas y caballeros negros al unísono Eunice
perras más calientes
Judah para leer y
venir hoy
y apagarme como estaba pensando se
aseguró de que mi compañero podría ayudarme tu
estelar rechazarme rechazar ver
[Música
]  yo mismo
[Música]
dijiste
dulce reunión
Jamaica y España fueron como la forma en que venimos
en el turno tú, ¿qué te pasa? nigga labios
este isoh muppet si notaste licor
Cockburn debe Omicron decir oh mi dios
convertirte es el mundo quien  realmente clavó el
cuchillo primero, sabes que no es así
sikita entubado a la
mujer Sacto alguna vez pruébalo solo dame una
mejor estar en casa con amigos
No me levanté mucho No me levanté mucho Yo
[Música]
No sé eso o tu mucho voto de condominio
ese sábado  mira, sé que todos sabemos
que ellos de ellos, boom, no, no recuerdo,
apúrate, es broma, no, mira a los hombres,
di por qué crees que sí.
estas deprimida soy
yo bebe  ve, no, no, cállalos
. Voy a volver
. Pienso en mi chica mala.
Arica a Skinner.
Oh.